Німеччина з 11 червня більше не отримує російський газ - на газогоні "Північний потік-1"
почалися ремонтні роботи, розраховані на 10 днів.
Однак багато німців бояться, що РФ не відновить постачання газу й після ремонту.
Вони бояться, що дефіцит та подорожчання газу серйозно вдарить по їхніх гаманцях.
Я побоююся, що цього року будуть нереально високі ціни на опалення.
Я читав, що доведеться заощаджувати чи не 1000 євро, бо ціни так зростуть.
Мені вже зараз погано, коли я думаю про наступну квитанцію за світло та опалення.
Торік у листопаді нам дуже сильно підвищили ціни на електрику на цей рік.
І мені страшно думати, що буде у квитанції за цей рік.
Я - єдиний годувальник у сім'ї з двома дітьми, яких треба прогодувати…
Важко буде.
Я чув, що треба готуватися до того, що взимку буде холодніше.
Але загалом я цілком і повністю за санкції проти Росії. Путіна треба зупинити!
Експерти кажуть, що побоювання виправдані лише частково
і базуються переважно на емоціях, а не на фактах.
Але масштаб недовіри до Росії такий, що найгірший варіант ніхто не виключає.
Проблема в тому, що на тлі складного інформаційного фону
та непрозорої комунікації люди починають вірити у теорії змови.
І по-друге, звичайно, дії самого "Газпрому" та російської сторони з того моменту,
як "Газпром" раптово відмовився від права власності на "Газпром Німеччина"
- все це дає підстави для теорій змов.
Наявних нині запасів газу в Німеччині вистачить максимум на два місяці.
Майже половина з 43 мільйонів будинків у ФРН опалюється газом.
Якщо тиск у газовій мережі впаде нижче певного рівня, вийдуть з ладу запобіжники
в сотнях тисяч газових обігрівачів. Після відновлення газопостачання
фахівцям доведеться вручну запускати кожен газовий котел.
Це означає масовий хаос, який може затягтися надовго.
Так, ми можемо спробувати зменшити споживання газу та працювати ефективніше
із заходами економії, але ми знаємо з усіх оцінок ситуації, що Німеччина
не зможе швидко компенсувати втрати російського газу.
Іншими словами, нам потрібно готуватися не просто до уповільнення економіки,
а до серйозної рецесії.
Ми отримаємо серйозну рецесію, що означає економічний спад приблизно на 5 відсотків.
Це можна порівняти з рецесією, яку ми пережили під час фінансової
та економічної кризи 2008-2009 років.
Тож це безперечно буде серйозне потрясіння для німецької економіки.
Мета німецького уряду - до 1 жовтня заповнити газосховища
не менше ніж на 80 відсотків. При цьому ще до зупинки "Північного потоку-1"
на щорічне техобслуговування "Газпром" знизив обсяги постачання газу
в Німеччину на 60 відсотків. Приводом нібито стало неповернення
після ремонту газової турбіни, яка використовувалася в інфраструктурі
"Північного потоку-1". Турбіна застрягла в Канаді через запроваджені санкції проти Росії.
Турбіна, яка використовується на компресорній станції Портова,
створена компанією Сіменс Енерджі, побудована на основі авіаційної турбіни
на заводах у Канаді, де її ремонтували.
Тільки там це можуть зробити. Канада запровадила санкції на товари
подвійного призначення.
Тобто вирішила не постачати до Росії товари, які можна використовувати
як у військовій, так і цивільній сфері.
Авіаційна турбіна - це, безумовно, товар подвійного призначення,
тому що їх можна використовувати в авіації, але не цю модель,
тому що це не авіаційна турбіна, а лише створена на основі авіаційної турбіни.
Після переговорів між Берліном та Оттавою, Канада погодилася повернути турбіну
до Німеччини, звідки вона у свою чергу зможе попрямувати до Росії.
Формально це не порушить санкції ані Канади, ані Євросоюзу.
У Берліні привітали це рішення.
Росія виправдовувала припинення постачання газу "Газпромом" тим,
що ця турбіна не повернулася відремонтованою з Канади.
Ми усунули цю причину, домовившись із Канадою про постачання цієї турбіни,
тепер вона повернеться до Росії. Таким чином, причина, через яку не можна
було постачати достатньо газу, по суті, відпала.
Тим часом Київ різко засудив рішення Канади та Німеччини повернути турбіну,
назвавши це поганим прецедентом у відповідь на шантаж з боку Росії.
Київ ще 22 червня поінформував західних партнерів, що Росія
має законтрактовані транзитні потужності через українську територію,
які не використовуються, і технічно може будь-якої миті відновити постачання.
На критику української влади в уряді Німеччини відреагували так.
Ми прийняли це до уваги, проте санкції ЄС не торкаються транзиту газу,
і на це є вагомі причини. Ми завжди говорили, що для нас вирішальним критерієм
для санкцій є те, що вони не повинні шкодити ЄС та Німеччині більше, ніж Росії.
У компанії Сіменс Енержді DW підтвердили, що турбіну повернуть до Німеччини.
Йдеться про аеродериваційну газову турбіну. Вони невеликі за розміром,
їх можна переправляти літаками. За словами представника компанії,
турбіна найближчим часом буде доставлена до Росії.
Утім, експерти схиляються до думки, що й після повернення турбіни
газ "Північним потоком-1" навряд чи піде в повному обсязі.
У чому ми можемо бути абсолютно впевнені, то це в тому, що Росія
в даний час хоче постачати менше газу. Тож ці технічні проблеми
не є єдиною причиною. Навіть якщо цю турбіну повернуть,
це лише одна з восьми турбін, встановлених на цій компресорній станції.
А це означає, що за її допомогою прокачування можна буде трохи збільшити,
але це не дасть можливості повернутися до 100 відсотків.
Наразі поставляється близько 40 відсотків запланованого обсягу,
а з цією турбіною з Канади можна буде поставити 60 відсотків.
Отже, проблеми на цьому точно не закінчаться.
Планова зупинка газогону "Північний потік-1" має тривати 10 днів.
Після цього стане ясно, чи перетворився газ остаточно на геополітичний
інструмент впливу 21 століття,
чи газовий апокаліпсис у Німеччині поки відкладеться.